SPEAKER: So far, we've talked
about how Kubeflow Pipelines
bring orchestration for
complex ML workflows,
giving you reproducible and
reliable experimentation.
And in our last
episode, I showed you
a prediction model ready to go.
Let's walk through
building a Kubeflow
Pipeline that uses this model.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Today, we'll go through a
sample ML app using Pipelines.
Check out the link
below if you want
to read more about building
Pipelines in a Jupyter
notebook.
I'll use the same model from
the last episode, where you'll
forecast how many Chicago
crimes are expected
to be reported the next day
based on how many were reported
over the previous days.
If you want to see more
details on the model itself,
check out the last video.
To create an ML app
on Kubeflow, we'll
walk through downloading
data from BigQuery,
creating a Kubeflow Pipeline,
including Google Cloud AI
platform components to
train and deploy the model,
submitting a job for
execution, and sharing
the Pipeline with others.
AI platform is
Google Cloud solution
to train ML models at scale,
host your trained models,
and serve models to
make new predictions.
We're going to run this
all from a Jupyter notebook
server running on Kubeflow.
On a running notebook, clone
the GitHub repo linked below
and access the AI
platform notebook.
If you run into any
authentication issues
while running the
notebook, make sure you're
on the latest
version of Kubeflow
and check out the documentation
around the user GCPSA secret.
Getting started with
the notebook code
will import dependencies
and define constants,
including the Kubeflow SDK.
As you begin to
create your Pipeline,
first define the
required parameters
like the Google Cloud project
ID and storage bucket.
Optional parameters
include your storage path
containing your untrained model,
the output storage bucket,
Pipeline name, and model name.
Similar to the Chicago crimes
notebook we covered last time,
start by defining a
download function that
will download trainer data
from Google Cloud BigQuery.
This time, you'll be using
the BigQuery Kubeflow Pipeline
component.
Remember that components include
inputs and outputs, which
can become inputs
to other components.
This component submits a
query to the BigQuery surface
and dumps output to our
cloud storage bucket.
Next, preprocess the data
and submit a training job
to AI platform.
Remember each step in a Pipeline
is a containerized task.
This means that
every component must
be packaged as a container.
To do this, you can load
a Pipeline component
via a local file or a component
URL, like a GitHub commit,
making sharing versions,
and reuse easy.
In this example,
we call a YAML file
that defines our next component,
which submits a training
job to AI platform.
While this is one way to
package a component that
makes sharing easier,
there are other ways
to do this, like using
the Pipelines SDK, which
includes classes and
methods for interacting
with Pipeline components.
Inputs for this component
include the cloud storage
location of our model,
the input parameters
to create a training job,
and the container image
URI to run this component.
It outputs a job ID and storage
path to the trained model.
The next component will
deploy the model with the ID
form our last output.
This YAML file describes
a Pipeline component
to deploy our trained
model from cloud storage
to an AI platform service.
Inputs include the cloud storage
path of the trained model,
and it outputs the storage path
containing our deployed model.
Now you can string together
all of these components
to define the Kubeflow
Pipeline-- just
define the data set storage path
and trainer output storage path
and call the download data
function, training function,
and model deployment function.
Finally, submit the
Pipeline for execution.
The Kubeflow Pipeline system
requires an experiment
to group Pipeline runs.
If you don't specify
an experiment,
it will use the default one.
It outputs a link to
both the experiment
and the run on Kubeflow.
Once you finish waiting for
the Pipeline to complete,
you can see it in
the Kubeflow console,
plus related logs from the run.
Here we've added a line of
code to compile our Pipeline,
so we can share it with others.
Once you run it, you can locate
the zip file in your notebook
server and download it.
The archive file can
be shared with others,
which lets them run it on
their own Kubeflow clusters.
You can upload a Pipeline file
to the Kubeflow Pipelines page
with versioning
control built in.
Once uploaded, you can
create runs from the same UI.
And Kubeflow has a form to
fill out input parameters,
so you can start runs right
away, giving you reusability
at your fingertips.
Once you've deployed the
Pipeline and tested it,
you can share the archive files,
so your teams can deploy it
on the production cluster.
In addition to sharing
the whole Pipeline,
you can also share
the component files,
making steps shareable
and reusable.
Stay tuned to learn where
else you can run Pipelines.
[MUSIC PLAYING]